[تصفيق]
حظوظ الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
بالرئاسه مجددا لا يعكر صفوها فقط منافسه
شرسه داخل الحزب الجمهوري وخارجه فملفه
الوثائق السريه لم يطوى بعد ويطارده كل
حين تحت خانه عرقله التحقيقات كشفت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست ان مساعدين اثنين لترامب نقل
صناديق من الاوراق قبل يوم واحد فقط من
زياره مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي لمقره في
ولايه فلوريدا لاستعاده المستندات في
اوائل يونيو
الجدول الزمني لحلقات هذه العرقله اتسع
اكثر هذه المره فالمعلومات اكدت قيام
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ومساعديه بما يشبه
البروفا لنقل تلك المستندات الحساسه حتى
قبل تلقيه امر الاستدعاء في مايو 2022
كيفيه احتفاظ ترامب هذه الوثائق في مكتبه
انتزعت حيزا من الاتهامات كذلك مع مزاعم
تركها في مكان مكشوف ومرئي وعرضها احيانا
على اشخاص اخرين
التوقيت وصفه المحققون بالمشبوه والمريب
لافتين الى امكانيه استخدام ذلك كدليل
احدث في توجيه الاتهام الترامب بعرقله
التحقيقات وسوء التعامل مع المعلومات
الحساسه او التهمتين معا هذه ليست اكثر من
مطارده مستهدفه وذات دوافع سياسيه ضد
الرئيس ترامب تم اعدادها للتدخل في
الانتخابات ومنع الشعب الامريكي من اعادته
للبيت الابيض
ورغم نفي ترامب المتكرر لارتكابه اي
مخالفات وتاطيرها بالملاحقه لدوافع سياسيه
الا ان عناصر الاف بي اي صادروا اكثر من
11 مجموعه من الوثائق السريه من مقره في
مرالاجو في اغسطس الماضي كان من المفترض
ان يعيدها الى الارشيف الوطني بعد تركه
البيت الابيض والتي قد تلعب دورا كبيرا في
عدم عودته اليه من جديد لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات